Mais en fait, l'état par défaut de notre cerveau
ressemble davantage à un moteur qui tourne au ralenti qu'une voiture à l'arrêt.
Certaines actions que nous croyons choisir de faire
sont en fait des actions que l'on est programmé à faire
quand on relâche la pédale de frein.
N'avez-vous jamais plaisanté en parlant de votre cerveau en pilote automatique ?
Devinez !
C'était sans doute le cas.
D'accord ?
Le pilote automatique du cerveau est dans une structure nommée striatum.
Le striatum détecte les conditions motrices émotionnelles et sensorielles
et il active n'importe quel comportement que vous avez adopté le plus fréquemment
dans le passé et dans des conditions identiques.
Savez-vous pourquoi je suis devenue neuroscientifique ?
Parce que je voulais comprendre ce qui me faisait tiquer.
(Rires)
Merci, merci.
J'ai envie de faire ce jeu de mots en public depuis des années.
(Applaudissements)
À l'université, en doctorat, j'ai étudié les facteurs génétiques
qui orchestrent les liens vers le striatum pendant le développement.
Je l'avoue, c'est mon ancienne plaque d'immatriculation.
(Rires)
Officiellement, je ne recommande à aucun doctorant
de choisir une plaque avec son sujet de thèse
à moins d'être prêt à ce que leurs expériences échouent
pendant deux ans.
(Rires)
J'ai fini par comprendre.
Mes expériences portaient sur les dysfonctionnements dans le striatum
en lien avec les comportements compulsifs.
C'est-à-dire des comportements contraints
par des besoins désagréables et impossibles à résister consciemment.
J'étais super ravie que mes souris développent
ce comportement compulsif
de frotter leur visage sans sembler pouvoir s'arrêter
même quand elles se blessaient.
Bon, je l'avoue, « ravie » n'est pas le terme approprié
car en fait, elles me causaient terriblement de la peine.
Je pensais qu'elles avaient des tics, preuve d'un dysfonctionnement du striatum.
Elles étaient vraiment compulsives
mais en fait, des examens approfondis ont montré
que ces souris montraient une aversion à interagir
et à faire connaissance avec d'autres souris.
C'était inhabituel et inattendu.
Ce résultat signifie que le striatum,
qui est sans l'ombre d'un doute impliqué dans tous les troubles compulsifs
est aussi impliqué dans les liens sociaux et dans notre capacité --
non pas nos liens sociaux, mais notre capacité à nous attacher.
J'ai donc approfondi le sujet
dans une discipline appelée les neurosciences sociales.
C'est un champ récent et interdisciplinaire.
J'y ai trouvé des rapports qui associent le striatum
pas seulement aux anomalies sociales chez les souris,
mais aussi chez les hommes.
Il s'avère que la neurochimie sociale dans le striatum
est liée à des choses dont vous avez déjà entendu parler.
L'ocytocine par exemple,
qui est l'hormone qui rend les câlins douillets et chaleureux.
Elle implique également la signalisation des récepteurs opiacés.
Nous avons des opioïdes naturels dans notre cerveau
et ils sont profondément liés aux processus sociaux.
Des expériences avec de la naloxone, qui bloque les récepteurs d'opiacés,
démontrent le caractère crucial de la signalisation de ces récepteurs
dans les interactions sociales.
Quand on administre de la naloxone, on en trouve dans le Narcan,
c'est un antidote contre l'overdose d'opiacés qui sauve des vies.
Mais administré à des personnes saines,
il interfère avec leur capacité à se sentir connectées
aux personnes qu'elles connaissent et qui leur sont chères.
Ne pas avoir le lien entre les opiacés et les récepteurs
nous empêche d'éprouver la gratification issue des interactions sociales.
Comme le temps m'est compté,
je vous épargne les détails scientifiques,
mais en bref, voici ce qu'il se passe.
Les effets de la déconnexion sociale via les récepteurs d'opiacés,
les effets des drogues addictives
et les effets d'une neurotransmission anormale
sur des mouvements involontaires et des comportements compulsifs,
convergent tous vers le striatum.
Or, le striatum et la signalisation des opioïdes à l'intérieur du striatum
sont profondément liés à la solitude.
Quand nous n'avons pas assez de signalisation aux récepteurs d'opiacés,
on se sent seul dans une salle remplie de personnes qu'on aime et qui nous aiment.
Les neuroscientifiques sociaux comme le Dr Cacioppo de l'université de Chicago
ont découvert que la solitude est très dangereuse
et qu'elle prédispose les gens
à des gammes complètes de maladies physiques et mentales.
Vous pouvez voir les choses ainsi : quand vous avez très faim,
n'importe quel aliment vous paraît merveilleusement bon.
C'est pareil, la solitude crée une faim dans le cerveau
qui hypersensibilise neurochimiquement notre système de gratification.
L'isolement social agit via ces récepteurs
vis-à-vis des opiacés naturels et d'autres neurotransmetteurs sociaux
en les poussant à laisser le striatum dans un état
tel qu'il surréagisse aux éléments signalant la gratification et le plaisir
de manière totalement exagérée.
Et dans cet état d'hypersensibilité,
notre esprit signale une insatisfaction profonde.
On devient agité, irritable et impulsif.
C'est à ce moment qu'il faut cacher le plateau de chocolats,
le mettre hors de ma portée car je les avalerais tous.
Absolument tous.
Ceci m'amène à parler d'un autre élément qui rend l'isolement social
si dangereux.
Sans cette capacité à nous lier socialement,
nous ressentons un besoin si vorace de rééquilibrer notre neurochimie sociale
que nous allons chercher à le soulager autrement.
Quand cet « autrement » est un anti-douleur opiacé ou de l'héroïne,
ça revient à viser notre mécanisme de récompense sociale
avec un missile à tête chercheuse.
Ce n'est donc pas très surprenant
que les gens deviennent dépendants si aisément.
L'isolement social,
si vous me le permettez,
contribue aux rechutes.
Des études montrent que les gens qui évitent davantage la rechute
sont souvent ceux qui ont des relations sociales nombreuses et réciproques,
au sein desquelles ils rendent service
et ils peuvent se sentir utiles.
Se rendre utile permet aux gens de se connecter.
Donc,
quand on n'a pas cette capacité à créer des liens authentiques --
et cette capacité de créer de vrais liens manque de plus en plus dans la société
tout comme les expériences qui nous transcendent.
Nous éprouvions cette transcendance
grâce à notre sentiment d'appartenance à nos familles et communautés.
Mais les communautés changent, partout.
Et la désintégration sociale et économique rend les choses encore plus compliquées.
Je ne suis pas la seule à pointer du doigt le fait
que c'est dans les régions les plus touchées par la crise
que les gens se sentent les plus accablés, ont perdu le sens de leur vie,
et que ce sont exactement ces régions
qui abritent les communautés les plus ravagées par les opiacés.
L'isolement social agit à travers le mécanisme de gratification du cerveau
pour aggraver cette situation et la rendre plus douloureuse.
Ça pourrait être cette douleur, cette solitude,
ce désespoir
qui mènent tant de personnes parmi nous à se créer un lien avec ce qu'ils peuvent.
La nourriture, par exemple,
ou les appareils nomades.
Ou, pour de trop nombreuses personnes, la drogue comme l'héroïne ou le fentanyl.
Je connais une personne qui a fait une overdose
et qu'on a ressuscitée au Narcan.
Elle était furieuse qu'on ne lui ait pas permis de mourir.
Imaginez un instant ce que l'on ressent dans un tel état de désespoir.
Mais le striatum s'avère aussi être une source d'espoir.
Car il nous donne des indices quand à comment retrouver ces gens.
Souvenez-vous que le striatum est notre pilote automatique,
qu'il dirige nos comportements routiniers
et qu'il est possible de le remodeler, de reprogrammer le pilote automatique.
Ça implique la plasticité neuronale.
La plasticité neuronale est la capacité de notre cerveau
à se reprogrammer,
à se remodeler afin de nous permettre d'apprendre.
Vous connaissez sans doute l'adage sur la plasticité :
des neurones qui s'excitent ensemble se lient entre eux.
D'accord ?
Nous avons donc besoin d'exercer nos comportements sociaux
et non pas nos comportements compulsifs, quand nous nous sentons seul,
ou quand notre assuétude à notre drogue nous taraude.
Nous avons besoin de répéter les stimuli qui excitent nos neurones
afin que le striatum se remodèle grâce à sa plasticité neuronale
et débranche le pilote automatique qui recherche l'héroïne.
La convergence des neurosciences sociales, de la dépendance
et des troubles compulsifs dans le striatum suggère
que ce n'est pas suffisant
d'inculquer au striatum des réactions plus saines face aux besoins compulsifs.
Nous avons besoin d'impulsions sociales
pour remplacer les comportements compulsifs induits par la drogue
car nous avons besoin de rééquilibrer neurochimiquement
nos mécanismes de gratification sociale.
Sans cela, nous restons dans un état de manque.
Quelle que soit notre application à remplacer la drogue par autre chose.
Je crois que la solution de la crise des opiacés réside dans notre exploration
des interventions sociales et psycho-spirituelles
car celles-ci agissent comme des neurotechnologies
dans les circuits qui gèrent les gratifications induites par la drogue.
Une possibilité est de créer et étudier des outils adaptables à grande échelle
qui permettent aux gens de se connecter
via des intérêts communs
et de se soigner avec des pratiques psycho-spirituelles.
Ces pratiques psycho-spirituelles peuvent être diverses :
des fans qui se réunissent à l'occasion de concerts musicaux ;
ou de parkours, où il y a un partage réciproque de la vulnérabilité de chacun
et un développement personnel ;
ou des choses plus conventionnelles, comme des rencontres de yoga
et des réunions centrées autour de vues plus traditionnelles
de la spiritualité.
Quoi que ce soit,
il faut activer absolument
tous les mécanismes neurotransmetteurs dans le striatum
qui incluent le traitement des liens sociaux.
Les média sociaux ne peuvent pas y parvenir.
Les médias sociaux ne nous encouragent pas tant à partager
qu'à nous comparer.
C'est la différence entre papoter avec quelqu'un
et avoir une conversation sincère et profonde en se regardant dans les yeux.
Les stigmates sont aussi une source d'ostracisme.
Des preuves étayent le fait qu'ils nous confinent dans la maladie.
Les stigmates font que les drogués se sentent plus en sécurité
parmi d'autres drogués.
Mais des groupes de guérison focalisés sur le rétablissement des liens sociaux
pourraient inclure des gens à la recherche de guérison
pour le spectre entier des troubles de la santé mentale.
Quand nous créons un lien autour de ce qui ne va pas,
nous créons un lien en tant qu'êtres humains.
Nous nous soignons de nos compulsions autodestructrices
qui sont en fait une réaction à la douleur de l'isolement.
On envisage souvent les maladies neuropsychiatriques
comme un spectre de phénomènes faisant partie de notre humanité,
et on supprime alors l'altérité
chez ceux qui se battent contre l'autodestruction.
On efface les stigmates
entre les médecins, les patients et les soignants.
Nous replaçons la question sur le sens d'être normal par rapport à être malade
sur le spectre des conditions humaines.
C'est sur ce spectre que nous pouvons créer des liens
et chercher la guérison ensemble de nos difficultés avec notre humanité.
Merci de m'avoir laissée partager cela.
(Applaudissements)